Let me read you some things.
Rogers rote.
Okay,
this is a good one.
This is cause this is his statements.
Here's some of it's
axiomatic presuppositions.
So this is what you need to cleave to.
If you're going to engage in
the process of Virginia therapy,
you have to want to be independent.
Now that's an interesting,
I don't know,
maybe we can actually have
a discussion about this.
You know,
Freud thought the oedipal complex was
universal and what he meant by that,
people usually don't have this discussion,
but we can give it a
shot and see how it goes.
What he meant by that was that
the,
that's struggling out of the family.
The primary family is very,
very difficult.
So I can give you an example.
So I had another client,
very bright guy,
second generation guy from Middle East.
And uh,
he was headed for a pretty good career.
He's a smart guy and he's,
he'd done a load of work
to get this career going.
Isn't that position that
was difficult to obtain.
You had to move to a different city
in order to pursue this career.
And his parents were very upset that
he was moving off the street they lived
yet.
Okay.
So
from the Western perspective,
roughly speaking,
this is where it gets tricky.
The proper thing to do on behalf of the
parents would have been to support him
in his attempts to be,
to establish himself independently about
the parent's perspective was you're
betraying the family by moving away.
Okay.
Now the question is,
you know,
is it reasonable to presume that
independence is an absolute value?
I mean,
we're having words about this,
that's for sure.
Wars have been going on for a long time.
For Rogers,
if you didn't value independence,
you couldn't get going
in this form of therapy.
Freud thought that all cultures were
eatable to one degree or another,
and you thought that wasn't
true for northern Europeans.
And that was part of the reason why
young and Freud came to a crossroads.
So
you think about that.
Okay.
In any case,
for Roger's only independence value,
individuals were suited for
client centered therapy.
Here's more acce.
Yes.
Honest
or
you're not.
That's another destination
to independence.
Turn point.
Good point.
I don't know if you can be completely
consistent with yourself and your family.
Well that,
that,
that's a very useful way of the way.
That's a very useful way of phrasing,
phrasing your question.
That's a very useful way
of phrasing the issue.
Can you be,
if you're honest,
does that mean you're independent?
It's a good question.
Might mean that because it means that
you're at least say again from the rod
next.
Let's take it from the
Rogerian perspective.
If you're speaking for yourself now,
that would be yourself in
relationship to other people,
the integrate itself,
right?
Not the kind of instrumentals,
useless self that's wandering
around causing trouble.
There's still your,
your unique position that
has to be contended with,
right?
And the fact that you're your own kind
of bounded entity with its own destiny
and path and its own particular
biological structure.
And it's possible that the way that
you define independence is that that
particular need is properly
integrated into the collective.
So cats a good,
that's a good issue.